this is Lois I love this woman's an  orphanage I needed gonna go finish  yourself get myself and that's where you  learn to speak English yes I was and God  gives you the strength yes with these  lovely children and here you sleep with  how many children I sleep with the 40  dreams when I move this to here I drink  the istake they are  [Music]  you  [Applause]  so we're hearing and amber village and  we're gonna go to so wedgie town so  we're very excited a mullah Shawnee and  Lois is the grandmother  there's a good day I have blessed cold  what have done in my life I didn't know  that we can meet you and me we can't  admit but the quad knows what I have  done you and me god bless you  yeah I'm suffering no house know what  you have done  [Music]  [Music]